hey guys I'm Greg and I'm dan dan and
Greg today are gonna check out the
trailer for the highly anticipated after
the last successful smash hit we now get
five nights at Freddy's sister location
trailer after did major success that was
five nights at Freddy's world and I'd
never played it
I loved the trailer I'm glad to see him
going back to horror I just really wish
he would have moved on from the five
nights at Freddy's name and done
something else well I mean I kind of
liked that it was that okay I like the
Halloween franchise in terms of movies
sure third one doesn't have Michael
Myers no one really likes that one so
this is kind of like the previous five
nights is sort of like that random
sequel is the worst would a lot of us
thought coming I don't know why we were
surprised when it was pulled off steam
so here we go guys are you ready for
this sister location train yeah that's
one we're back
mr. back now was legit
it's gonna be free-roaming
now
try
it's got a body
No
that's the picture I saw in his psyche
and I will have no part of it
like how they were showing like these
futuristic animatronic things determine
it's weird now he's gone for like a
little bit more sci-fi in a way yeah
they're like robots you know they're not
just like like Chuckie Cheese
animatronic seem like a whole it's
interesting because like what point in
time because everything is generally set
and five nights at Freddy's around the
80s except for the one that's like
thirty years in the future where the
[ __ ] does this take place and when I
wonder if we can explore the lore more
you know like have a neighbor talked
about Freddy's sister before there's
never been a game that has this talked
about you know Freddy's sister know now
it makes me wonder like okay who's
building mm-hmm does he intentionally
making them come to life there's some
like curse you know yeah you know with
Matt Pat's theory on the whole thing
about going like you know uh everything
was a dream and that's kind of what like
generically what everyone kind of came
to I don't know where this fits one to
the animatronics are super shiny now
turning three is gonna be free roaming
she was going through like an event or
something yeah which would be awesome
because sitting alone in a room as like
scary as it is because there's
absolutely nothing you can do I played a
alpha version of a free-roaming five
nights game and it was [ __ ] terrified
it yeah cool well why did you scream no
when she showed up because climb oh you
don't like flying I hate clowns I hate
clowns too I've grown a little bit more
using them but for most of my life I've
really hate clowns this literally
combines about 90% of my fears
animatronics and now clowns so you know
[ __ ] me right
and next thing you know the next one
Freddie's gonna have a snake for a penis
the snakes are my biggest fears oh my
god he has a puppet [ __ ] this is all my
fears this is literally all my fears
because body is now a hand puppet [ __ ]
alright well we're done I feel people
are gonna buy this one I don't think
it's gonna underperform like the last
one yeah I agree with you might not like
it sensationally performed but I think
it's gonna do better I think you're
gonna see like on YouTube you're gonna
have the like all the Let's Plays are
going to do it because that's what you
do I'll be interested because if the
game plays different because that's the
thing that always bugged me about five
nights is that the gameplay is sit in
room
yeah but they can roam around oh yeah
right now you're gonna be checking
behind you constantly yeah but then what
about the whole like security camera
think maybe it's our phone or something
like that yeah potentially you imagine
one of the vents oh yeah dude imagine an
oculus rift sub like the phone Zack here
you have to like a look at ya oculus
rift
five nights I'll come in people who are
humans if you're new to the channel you
can check out dan cybers channel cyber
nugget december not the cyber nods this
advert knight cyber channel that cyber
challenge the actual name of the chimp
he's also on instagram that cyber guy
mmm
and yeah curd to gaming he's the guy to
go to
I mean you look at him he looks like a
gamer that's what he is wearing
completionist shirt yeah I have like two
gaming friends and you could subscribe
to date to the real rejects because we
have enthusiasm and boyish charm yeah
whatever the hell else youtubers can
theater videos like comment subscribe
all of us yeah um we love you all we
love you all it's all about love I love
you right that's the part of the spirit
I love you yep the script I wrote on my
yeah we got my man yeah we love it's all
because of you guys
okay yeah yeah got it
okay great